one of the four chief organizers for the
massive women's March that took place on
Saturday is a quote Palestinian American
Muslim racial justice and civil rights
activist named Linda Sarsour Sarsour who
also served as a democratic national
convention delegate was honored by
President Obama's administration as a
champion of change fittingly she also
posed in Chicago with an alleged Hamas
financier fitting because Barack Obama
used to give speeches in honor of
Palestinian terror mouthpiece Rashid
Khalidi so what exactly drove star suers
ire during the women's March here's a
clue from 2014 quote ten weeks of paid
maternity leave in Saudi Arabia yes paid
and you're worrying about women driving
puts us to shame if you wonder why
hundreds of thousands of women declared
themselves brave for marching in favor
of taxpayer-funded condoms while doing
nothing for women abroad who live in
abysmal circumstances this would be it a
complete lack of perspective maybe one
reason Saudi Arabia is happy to pay for
maternity leave is because they bribed
their citizens not to rebel against the
autocratic regime through massive
welfare payments maybe another reason is
because the government wants to
encourage women to stay home rather than
working in Saudi Arabia as the weak
reports women can't get a passport
without the permission of a husband
father or other male Guardian most women
can't drive women are prevented from
wearing attractive clothing go to public
areas that those if you go to those
areas that are non segregated they won't
let you if you're a woman or even try on
clothes at stores this is just another
piece of evidence that the government
big enough to give you goodies is big
enough to take away your right and it
turns out that people who think Saudi
Arabia's maternity policies rather than
restrictions on female driving probably
shouldn't be a guide to female freedom
in the United States but the left would
prefer never to focus on such matters
since that would obligate them to favor
Western ISM rather than multiculturalism
abroad as well as at home so much for
the women's March I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
so many so many things to get you today
I am so excited about all at first the
the left had a a very strong reaction to
Donald Trump being sworn in on Friday
and it was all available in this little
nutshell video I think this embodied the
the primal fear of so many folks on the
left the outrage and also I couldn't
stop laughing at this for several days
this is just watch
[Applause]
Darth Vader no from this lady it's
spectacular
so she waits until Trump gets
inaugurated and then the nose screaming
to the sky
yeah I'm sure this is gonna win people
over it's not like I'm sure look I'm
sure that she just defeated Trump Trump
isn't gonna be president anymore because
this crazy lady is that atutor lady I
assume that's a lady
is screaming to the sky about Donald
Trump so all of that is spectacular
okay so before we jump into the
substance of the day and there's so much
to get to we have to say thank you to
our sponsors over at blue apron so
several years ago my wife said to me you
know what the most annoying thing about
cooking is the shopping the most
annoying thing is the shopping picking
the recipe and then having to go out and
shop and figure out what sort of
portions to get and where to get the
best ingredients blue apron solves all
of that and they solved the recipe
problem through two so what they do is
they allow you to pick from a list of
recipes and then they send you the
ingredients these fresh ingredients from
the recipes for less than $10 per person
per meal they deliver seasonal recipes
along with those pre-portioned
ingredients to make those great
home-cooked meals and also each meal
comes that step by step recipe it takes
40 minutes or less to prepare all of
their recipes everything is super fresh
they guarantee that all of their
ingredients are ready to cook or they
will make it right for you a lot of my
friends have tried blue apron and they
say that it's truly delicious a lot of
folks at the office are big fans of blue
in LA pretty much everybody uses blue
apron it's become a very big thing in
Los Angeles go to blue apron comm slash
Shapiro right now and you get and you
get a discount you get to get your first
three meals free with free shipping
first three meals free with free
shipping by going to blue apron comm
slash up here oh you will love how good
it feels and how good it tastes I
promise that as I say I know a lot of
people who use blue apron and they
really do enjoy it they love it it's
it's it's it's not expensive it is very
very fresh stuff and again those first
three meals get free with free shipping
by going to blue apron comm slash
Shapiro the meal cooked to order but
you're the one who actually makes it and
the ingredients that come fresh so it
doesn't feel all
gross like from a restaurant okay so
much to talk about here let's begin with
the anti-trump protests and the women's
March so the left can't deal with the
fact that Trump was sworn in on Friday
and we'll get to Trump's inaugural
speech in a second because yeah as
always we we like to be intellectually
honest here at the ben shapiro show and
something that we actually care about so
we're going to tell you the truth not a
bunch of crap that you want to hear
because if we did that then we might
have double the ratings but we'd also
have half the moral values so what we're
interested in here at the Ben Shapiro
show is actually telling you the truth
about what's happening in politics and
in culture but first we begin with this
truth the left does not know how to deal
with Donald Trump so at the inauguration
they're a bunch of people who go nuts
and they start burning trash cans and
they sent a limo on fire you can see
this this tape of this limo on fire this
picture of this limo on fire there are
rumors going around for a while is Jesse
Jackson's limo that turned out not to be
true it would have been beautifully
ironic if the protesters burned Jesse
Jackson's in protest of Trump but that
turned out I guess not to have been true
so they set this this limo on fire and
look at how many members of the media
there are right there they're just
itching to create this perception like
the world is burning like everybody's
going nuts the truth is people are upset
but the world is not burning nothing is
going nuts it's all gonna be okay the
Republic is pretty durable we've
survived a lot worse than Donald Trump
we've survived a lot better than Donald
Trump
the idea that everything is gonna go
nuts and and cars will burn everyone
will die it's not true it's a bunch of
crap so no so the left is burning things
and if they think this is gonna win
allies I don't know why they think it's
gonna win allies but they did this and
the media covered it up the wazoo be
like one burning car 200 members of the
media and you would see that there was
again there are those burning trash cans
I guess there are 219 total people who
were arrested during the inauguration
that's not a huge number of people
arrested it's some people arrested but
the way that the media were playing it
right and left were that there were
these massive riots taking place in
Washington DC not true
there is a pretty minimal number of
people who are very upset meanwhile the
media really played up his women's March
so the day after the inauguration all
across the land women left their homes
and went out to march in the streets for
something
that we don't know what it is honestly I
don't know why they were marching they
were just out there to signal that they
don't like Donald Trump or something no
one knows quite why what do you want we
don't know when do you want it now so
this so everybody apparently was
incumbent on everybody to bring a sign
and they all brought signs a huge number
of these signs were about abortion and
also about Pussycats for some reason I
assume that the signs about Pussycats
were not in fact about Pussycats they
were just about Donald Trump and his
comments on the Access Hollywood bus so
some of these signs you see like this
one is just sick right it's a it's a
bleeding coat hanger that says on it
never again I don't know if these people
understand irony at all but you're using
coat hanger to kill babies like a
million babies a year so I'm not sure
whether that's an anti-abortion sign or
a pro-abortion sign if that's a
pro-abortion sign comparing not allowing
people to murder babies in the womb to
the Holocaust is a weird comparison
that's one I haven't seen before
also I love these ones that were
produced by Nair all pro-choice America
the National Abortion Rights Action
League they don't like to call
themselves that anymore because they
don't like to use the word abortion but
they produce these pre-made signs and
say keep your laws off my and then it's
a picture of a pussycat
right okay mmm a couple of points about
about this particular tack people were
wearing what they were calling
hats like cats but hats okay and
these were supposed to protest Donald
Trump cos Donald Trump is such a sexist
if you want to drive Americans out of
your camp a quick way to do it is just
keep saying things like hats over
and over and over and then talking about
female anatomy a lot of these signs are
super obscene there are a lot of kids
who showed up to this thing and there
are a lot of really obscene signs like
that there was we can look at some more
of these here's here's some more of
these signs as we stand up for our human
rights plan at dignity bodies diversity
health social justice equality America
women environment integrity it's a lot
of things to stand up for and when do
you sit down and then and then and these
are some of the more innocuous signs we
can see another another picture of the
signs this is the people holding up the
signs of Trump just saying nope and
we're watching but these are these are
the not obscene signs some of the really
obscene signs like had full
pictures of vaginas like there's one
that said read my lips but the the Ellen
lips for some reason was just a giant
vagina and then there was another one
that said the patriarchy can suck my
bleep right and then if this is supposed
to make people feel bad about Donald
Trump I'm confused
half of the reason that the Trump tape
was offensive is because of the casual
way that he was addressing the female
anatomy if you just keep shouting the
word cat without the cat over and
over and over all that's gonna happen is
you desensitize people to the idea that
it's kind of offensive to use that word
publicly all you end up doing is just
like your vulgarity is making from small
Garrity more acceptable not less
acceptable but people in this women's
March don't understand that or don't
care the women's March didn't accomplish
anything other than to make people feel
solidified I guess in their opposition
to Trump apparently it Nate Silver did
something I thought that was interesting
he looked at how many people will
actually march in various areas of the
country what he found was 80% of all the
people marched and were marching in
areas Hillary won so it doesn't matter
right doesn't matter though it wasn't
like there's some big ups well in Ohio
and Pennsylvania in Wisconsin all the
people who showed up we're in Washington
DC and in Los Angeles okay so the
women's March happens and the media make
a huge deal out of it it's the biggest
deal that ever happened the March for
Life is happening this week they will
immediately ignore the March for Life
will have twice as many people in DC
alone as this March had across the
country it won't matter
they'll proclaim that it didn't even
happen they'll cover on page 812 of the
New York Times that is actually media
bias well get to the media bias in in a
second first we have to we have to point
out also that the celebrities got
involved in this women's March Madonna
said that she she went to the women's
March and then she said she wanted to
blow up the White House which is
acceptable language if you are a a crazy
old kook that has more Botox in her than
Nancy Pelosi's entire warehouse of Botox
that exists in San Francisco it's a
secret but you but Madonna goes up there
and here's what she has to say about the
White House yes I'm angry yes I am
outraged yes I have thought an awful lot
about blowing up the White House
well hold on if Ted Nugent said that
with Obama there how fast you think
Secret Service would be there pretty
pretty damn quickly right I mean come on
but Madonna can say it and I guess
people just assume the botox has infused
her brain and so she can't actually
think anymore that that's pretty amazing
stuff Ashley Judd who you remember was
supposed to run for Senate in Kentucky
she hasn't made a movie since like 1932
I think she doesn't made a good movie
since 1918 like the invention of the
motion picture Ashley Judd was in it and
she was she ever in a good movie I'm not
sure she was ever in a movie but she
used to be she used to be a decent
actress and very pretty now she's just
Ashley Judd so here's Ashley Judd
talking about Donald Trump I am not as
nasty as a swastika painted on a pride
flag and I didn't know Devils could be
resurrected but I feel Hitler in these
streets a mustache traded for a toupee
Nazis renamed the cabinet's electro
conversion therapy the new gas chamber
shaming the gay out of America turning
rainbows into suicide notes I am NOT as
nasty as racism fraud conflict of
interest
homophobia sexual assault transphobia
white supremacy can suffer there because
she's crazy and we're running out of
time so Ashley Judd says that the toupee
is the new Hitler is the new Hitler
mustache which is interesting she also
says she compares the gas chambers to
electro conversion therapy this is a
myth that they've been purveying about
Mike Pence it's not true the idea that
he's in support of electrocuting gay
kids but she's saying all this stuff and
again if they think that this is somehow
going to win them converts I don't know
who the hell they're talking to who are
they talking to
dudes a Shia LaBeouf think he's winning
converts to the anti-trump cause with
behavior like this her Shia LaBeouf
fresh off being dragged out of a
Broadway show because he's totally
insane screaming at the spur this is
best performance since since at least
transformers 2
[Music]
yes I can't imagine that Americans are
not paying attention to - I can't
imagine the Americans are ignoring all
of this stuff they're paying attention
and they're going if this is how the
left responds I thought the Trump was
supposed to be crazy right
Trump was supposed to be the nutcase
uh-huh uh-huh yeah you're making a real
difficult for for Americans to turn away
from Trump when you act like this gang
okay we have to say thank you to another
advertiser and then we'll get to Trump's
inaugural which I want to talk about in
an honest way as I say honesty above all
else so if you are in dire need of
casual wear if you like sweatpants or
sweatshirts or underwear or great just
great socks all of this you can get it
Mac Weldon calm so Mac Weldon calm they
believe in smart design and premium
fabrics and simple shopping they are the
most comfortable underwear socks shirts
under shirts hoodies sweatpants that you
will ever wear I own a bunch of their
gear and it is super comfortable in fact
I threw out all of my other underwear I
only open underwear now because it is in
fact the most comfortable underwear that
I can wear upon me it is it is
spectacular they also have a line of
silver underwear and shirts that are
naturally antimicrobial which means that
your if you are wearing a sweatshirt
you're going to stink less which is
which is great Mac Weldon accom is where
you go to get their gear it is top of
the line as soon as I get home I don't
just wear these nay I don't wear these
snazzy outfits at home I actually get
into casual wear so I spend a lot of my
time in MAPP welds and wear and Mac
Weldon there's a reason for that it's
super comfortable and it is classy
looking Mac Weldon calm you get twenty
twenty percent off your order if you use
promo code Shapiro promo code Shapiro
Mac Weldon comm ma CK Weldon calm and
get 20% off when you use that promo code
Shapiro again top-of-the-line fabrics
top-notch clothing okay so we will so
we'll jump into the the Trump inaugural
men will sign off but first I want to
give a quick note on the Trump inaugural
address to to folks
who
been waiting so it makes me sad we
didn't have Friday shows yet that I
couldn't respond immediately to the
Trump inaugural but of course the mo the
biggest takeaway was the fact that
Donald Trump actually channeled Bane
from Batman in the middle of this speech
this is the actual mashup and giving it
back to you the people it actually is a
direct quote which is amazing but here's
the thing here's the thing you know this
is obviously facetious Trump is not vain
but these sort of populism that Trump
was espousing this nationalist populism
has nothing to do with conservatism and
we're gonna have to break on Facebook
and and on YouTube but you go over to
Daly wire.com to see why we'll go
through his entire inaugural then we'll
get to Sean Spicer we're gonna do all of
it in a very short period of time before
Andrew Clavin breaks down the door with
an axe so Daly wire.com if you want to
become a subscriber watch the rest
become part of the mailbag on Thursdays
make sure that you can watch the rest of
my show live you also get right now a
signed copy of a free signed copy of my
novel true allegiance and more goodies
soon to come daily we're calm eight
bucks a month and if you get that annual
subscription you get a free signed copy
of my book thank you and join us there
right now go there sign up right now and
you can watch the rest over on the most
conservative the most popular
conservative podcast in America
[Music]
you